[Music]
hey everyone its Peter Brown reading
Alessandro barbosa's review of the
forest the broad premise of the forest
is far from unique the plane crash lands
on a seemingly deserted island and you a
lone survivor have to figure out a way
to survive it's not long however until
this familiar setup turns an unexpected
corner and the forest evolves into a
uniquely harrowing adventure that you
won't soon forget
blood-curdling screeches fill the night
and glowing eyes watch you from a
distance your new home island isn't as
empty as it appears
cannibals inhabit the grassy fields and
pristine lakes around you watching your
every move they're the source of the
forest ever-present tension you might
expect mindless monsters like this to
attack on sight but their behavior is
erratic sometimes they'll charge forward
to unsettle you during daylight but stop
just outside striking distance to simply
stare at you in silence other times they
might faint a retreat before leaping up
into surrounding trees and getting
behind you the settlement you eventually
create is invaded by waves of larger
more imposing foes who you pray will
retreat as you thin their numbers the
forest enemies aren't easy to predict
which makes each encounter a thrill
the breath of enemy types is impressive
too and the forest isn't straight from
leaning into the weird either as you
explore the island more and dive into
terrifying pitch black caverns enemies
transform into terrifying body horror
figures amalgamations of appendages that
bellow deep disturbing howls they're
frightening to behold and even scarier
to fight the force does a good job of
trickling out these surprises while
you're already struggling to manage your
vital meters and resources it's also
imperative that you keep a close eye on
the quality of the resources you find
not every berry bush contains a bounty
that won't poison you and that all still
water is safe to drink meat you gather
from hunted animals will rot if not
cooked quickly none of the resulting
illnesses are serious enough to dissuade
you from eating questionable food to
stave off death but needing to think
twice about what you eat has an
additional layer to the standard
hunter-gatherer gameplay base
construction is equally engrossing due
to the sheer number of structures you're
able to build the forest doesn't Gate
it's creative building with elusive
blueprints instead from the outset it
gives you a notebook filled with
outlines for structures knowing how to
build shelters gardens and defenses
isn't the challenge the forest wants to
impose instead it shifts this on to the
risky task of acquiring resources to
build at all chopping down trees for
logs or scouting a route to clean water
is paramount in your first few days on
the island and once you establish
yourself this goal shifts to fortifying
your position with complex spike traps
and tree swings the construction of
which is deeply satisfying building has
a tangible effect on the island in
several ways resources like small game
and shrubs will respawn over time but
larger trees will remain felled for the
entirety of your stay you might turn a
dense forest into an open field of
stumps not long after you start but
that'll also give enemies a clear line
of sight into your doings the more you
impose yourself in the island the more
aggressive your aggressors become
patrols will grow and the more monstrous
creatures will emerge from their caves
for an all-out assault the force doesn't
force you to play in any specific way
though so a more reserved nomadic
approach is sometimes safer and more
viable
crafting smaller items plays a big part
when it comes to personal safety to your
inventory screen allows you to combine
items you've collected to create new
tools from something as simple as
combining a few sticks and stones to
make an axe to creating high-powered
explosives using a combination of
wristwatches electrical bores and spare
change the number of items you can both
collect and craft is vast but the
inventory page eventually becomes
cumbersome and overwhelming to navigate
and with only four customisable hotkeys
you don't actually have a lot of easy
access to what you want in a pinch at
the very least the forest never feels
too overbearing you'll always be able to
depend on your crafted weapons as they
aren't hampered by durability your
pocket letter will help you see in the
dark never running out of vital fluid
either this frees you from the burden of
worrying about the lifespan of any
potential upgrades you can make you're
incentivized to craft upgrades to
weapons that improve their damage and
speed while other combinations that you
create more illuminating torches with
limited burning times exploration and
survival games is usually tied only to
your immediate well-being but the forest
features a narrative slowly uncovered by
exploration and incidental environmental
storytelling abandoned camps are great
hunting ground for modern resources but
they also hint at past events cannibal
villages feature gory displays of
victims but also contain vital clues
small photographs videotapes and
magazines that flesh out a conspiracy
with the island at the center with a kid
there the forest doesn't have to be a
lonely experience and it offers
cooperative player for up to eight
people the time spent getting a
fortified settlement up and running is
drastically reduced then but remains
just as compelling cooperative play does
however deflate tension larger groups of
enemies become easier to deal with and
the fear of diving into caves alone is
undercut by both voice chat and the fact
that enemies don't really scale
according to your party size the forest
might be silly fun with friends but it's
best when playing alone yeah guys I got
this
[Music]
guys take a break I got this super swell
now guys
there's a lot to think about when it
comes to surviving in the forest but the
balance between each of its interlocking
parts keeps the game moving at a
riveting pace for every danger the
island offers there's a smart solution
around a corner combined with
unpredictable enemy actions and
captivating horror set pieces the forest
strikes a compelling balance between
survival and horror
[Music]